[Musique
] tu te moques de moi
oh
est-ce que cette merde est vraiment
apparue en mode cosplay complet c'est le gars que waller
nous donne je t'ai dit qu'elle nous baise
elle ne nous baise pas c'est qu'un aigle sur
sa banquette arrière
elle nous baise
hey
scooch
pourquoi  toi dans ton costume
costume c'est un uniforme et c'est tout
neuf donc je vais l'étirer pour le rendre
plus confortable avant d'aller en mission
peut-être que je suis stupide mais pourquoi voudriez-vous même
porter ça en mission une
chemise rouge vif  et les pantalons blancs ne sont pas vraiment
propices à se cacher dans l'ombre les
gens voient cet uniforme et font peur
dans leur cœur ce que les autres
gens du village essaient
pourquoi y a-t-il un pygargue à tête blanche dans votre voiture qui est
également vous les gars travaillez sans moi
eagley est ton animal de compagnie aigle ouais
est ton chien nommé toutou d'
accord as-tu une fille nommée
fille
joseph le pédigo d'un mec beaucoup
toi